much like how Snow White was mostly
fueled on emotions Pinocchio is very
similar it's not even really based on a
fairy tale it's based on a book and a
very odd deranged dark book as well
yeah the movies dark - but good cut the
books downright sadistic we're in a
fairy tale you just know what sort of a
magical world where magical things can
happen this world treats it a little
differently I mean there are magical
things like the Blue Fairy that brings a
puppet to life but then how about the
fact that there's just a fox and a cat
walking around like normal people
I remember how blown away they were that
they saw a puppet boy walking around and
all I could think that myself is why
isn't anybody blown away that there's a
giant Fox and a giant cat just walking
around well it's just that kind of world
where things like that can happen if
there's anything Disney is good at it's
having us go along with things that
don't make sense and this movie does it
pretty well Geppetto makes a puppet boy
wishes one night that he were real and
the Blue Fairy comes and makes it happen
it's ironic because probably the film
should be centered around Geppetto he's
the one that has a past he's the one
that actually has some character
Pinocchio is just sort of born with his
personality so the fact that he has to
learn lessons and be given a conscience
is kind of strange because the Blue
Fairy just sort of made him up didn't
she if you want him to learn lessons why
didn't you just have it where the
lessons were already learned but again
I'm totally over analyzing this
Pinocchio comes across a bunch of
strange adventures and learns a bunch of
lessons along the way and the visuals
they used to have him learn these
lessons sticks with us even today the
nose growing longer when you're lying
trying into a donkey when you've been
bad you don't forget strangeness like
this that often Pinocchio is a pretty
likable character and I like the fact
that they do make him for like him a
better term a real boy he isn't just
pitch perfect he is gullible he does
want to do bad things sometimes it
doesn't mean he's a rotten kid it just
means he's a kid what sets him apart
though is that he does learn his lesson
and he does try to do better he has a
conscience named Jiminy Cricket who I'm
just gonna say out there I never enjoyed
even as a kid yeah I know that means I
have no heart and I'm going to hell or
whatever you want to say but I just
don't like this guy
and you get in trouble and you don't
know right from wrong give a little bit
so I just didn't find that charming I
didn't find him that funny
his voice sort of grated on me but he
sings that one song and everybody's
putty in his hands I don't know I was
always waiting for Pinocchio to step on
him again the creepy imagery is sort of
up tin this movie much like it wasn't
Snow White except this time is to have
everything always turning out okay this
time it wasn't always okay a bunch of
misbehaving boys are brought to an
amusement park and then turned into
donkeys where they're gonna be used in
mining shafts and that's it you never
see them again the guy running the place
is never defeated the boys can't talk
anymore
god knows what they're doing with the
ones who can it's pretty friggin grim as
kids films go the risk however does come
back to the typical Disney formula after
a relatively exciting climax Pinocchio
gets mashed into a bunch of rocks and
loses his life again he can spin his
head around but some rock skills I don't
but the Blue Fairy comes back and sees
his sacrifice and brings him back
everybody in the audience is filled with
joy and of course Jiminy Cricket sings
that song that nowadays is almost
causing some controversy okay not major
controversy but people have been
debating whether or not this is a good
message this is the song that Disney
used all the time it's practically their
biggest trademark but some people think
that just promotes laziness or a lying
belief that everything will be okay if
you just believe hard enough well you
could make that argument I have yet to
see a kid that totally fell for this or
even more depressing an adult I think
kids are smarter than we give them
credit for kids are always gonna be
aware that there's bad things in the
world there's things they're gonna be
afraid of and that closing their eyes
and wishing isn't always gonna solve a
problem I think most people connect to
it because it's a symbol of hope rather
than realistic planning that sometimes
unexpected good things can happen and
they can come out of nowhere they can
come when you least suspect it so never
give up the idea that all hope is gone I
don't know that's what I got out of it I
think that's what most people get out of
it and I think that's what most people
get out of the film as well it runs the
Disney game at that most of us enjoy at
times bright and colorful but of our
times dark and scary threatening and
doubtful but always with that ray of
hope that sees us through doesn't always
make a whole lot of sense but they
create a world where it doesn't need to
it's a world where anything can happen
even when you least suspect